this is a classic Italian wedding soup
it is one of the most Savory soups that
you're ever going to eat the first thing
I do is make the meatballs I always make
them too big for this soup maybe it's
compensation I don't know try to make
them as small as you can you should get
at least 20 meatballs with one pound of
meat traditionally you would not fry the
meatballs in Italian wedding soup but I
do you're going to get such a better
flavor look at all those brown bits that
are left behind that's what's going to
be the flavor of your soup you're going
to go in with some onions carrots and
garlic and once that garlic is fragrant
I go ahead and fill her up with some
chicken broth bring it to a boil and
then add your meatball lower to a simmer
let those finish cooking for 15 minutes
and you know I always go in with that
parmesan rind add the orzo for another
15 minutes then finish it off with some
spinach or some escarole and that's how
you feed your whole family click that
follow button for more recipes like this
and get the full recipe at always fromc
scratch.com